Todo empezó en Crimea y todo terminará en
Crimea” –Volodymyr Zelenskiy
La península de Crimea es el auténtico elefante
en la habitación de todas las discusiones
sobre la guerra de Ucrania. Durante años,
fue algo así como la Ibiza de Ucrania, ahora
es la manzana de la discordia.
Y es que, veréis... los ucranianos quieren
recuperarla. Pero no está para nada claro
que Estados Unidos y Europa les vayan a ayudar
en este territorio. Esto no lo decimos nosotros.
Lo dice el mismísimo Antony Blinken, que
es el secretario de Estado de Estados Unidos.
Atentos.
(Antony Blinken desaconseja que Ucrania retome
Crimea
El secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
tiene miedo de que los esfuerzos para reclamar
la península ocupada por Rusia sean una línea
roja para Vladimir Putin - The Telegraph)
¡Habéis oído bien! Y diréis ¿Por qué?
Pues dos razones. La primera es que, a primera
vista, recuperar Crimea parece una misión
imposible. La segunda y más importante es
que Crimea podría ser una razón suficiente
para que Putin pulsara el botón nuclear.
Y es que veréis, para los rusos, esta península
ni siquiera se considera una parte más de
Ucrania: es un territorio aparte.
Incluso hay una canción muy conocida, Sdelan
v SSSR”, “Hecho en la URSS”. La versión
Aliexpress del mítico “Born in the USA”
que empieza diciendo “Ucrania y Crimea,
Bielorrusia y Moldavia ¡Ese es mi país!”
Sólo que, a diferencia del tema de Bruce
Springsteen, que es una canción protesta,
este es un tema ultra nacionalista. “Ucrania
y Crimea, Moldavia y Bielorrusia”... Es
decir, que en el imaginario ruso, Crimea es
un territorio distinto, un lugar muy particular
con su propio estatus claramente diferenciado.
Y tienen ciertas razones para pensar así:
la península de Crimea tiene su propia historia,
muy distinta a la del resto de Ucrania ¡No
solo eso! Desde el punto de vista geopolítico,
es un auténtico regalito. Podríamos decir
que fue el auténtico premio gordo que logró
Putin en 2014. De hecho, fue el único territorio
que se anexionó sin ningún miramiento. Quiero
decir, cuando los rusos llegaron a Ucrania
en 2014, no se anexionaron el Donbás. Al
menos, no oficialmente. Sin embargo, el Kremlin
considera que Crimea es tan ruso como el mismísimo
San Petersburgo. En resumen: Kyiv quiere recuperar
Crimea, Moscú está dispuesta a todo para
evitarlo y Washington no tiene claro que vaya
a tomar partido en este caso. Así que en
el vídeo de hoy vamos a preguntarnos: ¿Por
qué Crimea es tan importante para Rusia?
¿Cómo podría recuperarla Ucrania? Y finalmente
¿Qué escenarios podemos esperar? Hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas, pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
A estas alturas, todos tendréis el mapa de
Crimea en la cabeza. Sin embargo, el diablo
está en los detalles. Por eso, antes de meternos
en la HISTORIA de este territorio, vamos a
centrarnos en su geografía.
La península de Crimea está habitada por
2,4 millones de personas.
La ciudad más importante es SEBASTOPOL, con
547.000 habitantes. Ahí es donde está ahora
la sede de la flota naval de Rusia en el Mar
Negro.
Controlar este enclave significa controlar
todo el mar de Azov y todo el norte del Mar
Negro. De hecho, hasta 2014, Ucrania tenía
12 puertos operativos en su costa. Para Rusia
Crimea es vital para tener una salida al mar
Negro y el mar Mediterráneo. Es uno de sus
pocos puertos de aguas calientes.
Además, sus aguas territoriales tienen yacimientos
de gas probados. Por un lado tenemos los yacimientos
de Skifska, al este de la península. Por
el otro, los del mar de Azov. En este caso,
sería relativamente fácil explotar este
gas porque el mar de Azov es el mar menos
profundo del mundo: no supera los 15 metros.)
Pero lo más importante de Crimea es que está
perfectamente protegida por su geografía.
Tomarla por mar es misión imposible para
Ucrania. Recordad que Rusia tiene a toda su
flota del mar negro por aquí. Y diréis ¡Pues
que la tomen por tierra! ¿Verdad? ¡No tan
rápido! Ya os he dicho que el diablo está
en los detalles. A simple vista, Crimea parece
una península más... pero cuando nos acercamos
al istmo que une Crimea con Ucrania, encontramos...
¡Al diablo!
(Como veis, toda esta zona está llena de
lagos y zonas pantanosas. En realidad, sólo
hay 3 puntos que conectan la península con
Ucrania. Esto que veis aquí es el istmo de
PEREKOP, que tiene un ancho de entre 5 y 7
kilómetros. Rusia ya lo ha fortificado con
un sinfín de trincheras y dientes de dragón.
Por otro lado, tenemos la península de CHONHAR,
por donde pasa una autopista rodeada por lagos.
De nuevo, una entrada muy fácil de proteger.
Finalmente, tenemos la “punta de ARABAT”.
Otro lugar que los rusos podrían bloquear
fácilmente.)
En otras palabras, que entrar a Crimea po
r tierra es misión casi imposible ¿Es posible?
Todo es posible en esta guerra. A estas alturas
no podemos descartar otro golpe de estado
en Rusia ni cualquier otro escenario. Ahora
bien, entrar en Crimea sería una operación
militar tan ambiciosa como el desembarco de
Normandía. Y bien, ahora que ya hemos visto
la geografía, vamos a por la historia...
porque, creedme, hay muchos detalles que necesitamos
saber.
T1(TIERRA DE INVASIONES)
Hemos visto que Crimea es muy difícil de
invadir. Sin embargo, a lo largo de la historia,
hay un sinfín de imperios que lo han intentado.
Esta península tiene una importancia geopolítica
enorme. De hecho, no es casualidad que la
Conferencia de Yalta, que para muchos supuso
el comienzo de la Guerra Fría, se celebrara
en... ¡Yalta! Que es una ciudad que está
aquí, en Crimea.
Entre 1238 y 1449, la península perteneció
al Imperio Mongol. Después, entre 1448 y
1783 fue un khanato subordinado al Imperio
Otomano. Eso explica que parte de la población
de Crimea sean los llamados TÁRTAROS de Crimea,
que son musulmanes. Finalmente, en 1783, el
Imperio Ruso aprovechó la debilidad de los
Otomanos para invadir este territorio.
Y sí, en este caso, entraron a Crimea por
tierra. De hecho, lo intentaron en 3 campañas
distintas durante varios años ¿Consiguieron
tomarla? ¡Sí! Pero no sin pagar un precio
muy alto. En cualquier caso, los zares se
hicieron con este territorio, que pasó a
formar parte de la llamada “NOVOROSIYA”
o “Nueva Rusia”: que incluía otras zonas
como Odessa, en la actual Ucrania.
Desde el primer momento, los zares rusos tuvieron
un problema con la población local: los tártaros
eran musulmanes y no aceptaban la autoridad
de los cristianos ortodoxos. Por eso, desde
Moscú hicieron su estrategia típica: RUSIFICAR
Crimea enviando población de otras zonas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
termina la historia!
Como os he dicho, Crimea es demasiado jugosa
como para que nadie la quiera invadir. Así
es como en 1853 estalló la llamada “Guerra
de Crimea”. En este caso, Rusia se enfrentó
a las tropas de los Otomanos, los británicos
y los franceses. Y diréis ¿Qué pintaba
Francia y Reino Unido en esta historia? Pues
muy simple: querían apoyar al Imperio Otomano
- la actual Turquía - para evitar... ¡El
expansionismo ruso! Cómo veis, esto del expansionismo
ruso no es nada nuevo.
Y lo que parecía una fortaleza inexpugnable
terminó cayendo en manos de los ingleses
y los franceses. En este caso, consiguieron
tomar Sebastopol por mar ¡Cierto! Fue una
victoria pírrica. En este caso, el cólera
y la disentería terminaron acabando con decenas
de miles de soldados... y, finalmente, Rusia
mantuvo el territorio hasta 1917.
Y diréis ¿Qué pasó en 1917? ¡Exacto!
La guerra civil rusa. En este caso, los tártaros
de Crimea aprovecharon la inestabilidad en
Moscú para proclamar la “República Popular
de Crimea”. Pero esta nueva república duró
muy poco. En seguida los bolcheviques la volvieron
a tomar. Durante las siguientes décadas,
esto fue una República dentro de la Federación
Rusa que, a su vez, estaba dentro de la Unión
Soviética. Hasta 1941 ¿Qué pasa en 1941?
Pues que los alemanes la vuelven a invadir.
En este caso, el ejército nazi entró por
el estrecho de Kerch.
Pero, de nuevo, las tropas soviéticas la
recuperaron. En este caso, Stalin volvió
a hacer la jugada más típica de Moscú:
volver a RUSIFICAR la zona ¿Cómo? Deportando
a 200.000 tártaros y enviando población
rusa de otras zonas.
Y os preguntaréis ¿ W Pero cuándo llegó
a ser Crimea parte de Ucrania? Pues tenemos
que esperarnos hasta el año 1954. El por
entonces líder soviético, NIKITA KHRUSHCHEV,
decidió que la Península de Crimea se fuera
del Soviet Ruso al Soviet Ucrania ¿Por qué?
Pues por una cuestión de pura logística.
La ruta más lógica para enviar recursos
a esta península pasa por Ucrania. Así que
lo más lógico es que esta zona se gestionase
desde Kyiv. A fin de cuentas ¿Qué importaba?
Fuera Rusia o fuera Ucrania, seguiría siendo
parte de la Unión Soviética. En ese momento
la caída y la disolución de la URSS no se
contemplaba.
Y así es como Crimea se convirtió en el
destino vacacional favorito de las élites
soviéticas. De hecho, muchos gerifaltes del
partido tenían una residencia vacacional
en la zona. Y así es como llegamos a 1991:
año donde Ucrania se independiza ¿Qué pasa
desde entonces? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(LA IBIZA DE UCRANIA)
Os presento a... la República de KAZANTIP
¡Tranquilos! No se trata de un nuevo país.
Durante años, la República de Kazantip fue
algo así como la madre de todas las raves.
Una macrofiesta en la playa que atraía a
gente de toda Europa. Crimea era también
la Ibiza de Ucrania: playas de ensueño, fiestas
glamourosas y todo a precios mucho más baratos
que los de la Ibiza original. Y la comparación
con Ibiza no es por casualidad. Desde el punto
de vista político, Crimea era una especie
de ISLA en toda Ucrania. Si sois veteranos
seguidores de VisualPolitik, ya sabéis que
este país estaba dividido en dos grandes
poblaciones: rusoparlantes y ucranianoparlantes.
La mejor muestra de esto son los mapas electorales
en las zonas con más rusoparlantes solían
ganar los partidos más cercanos a la cultura
rusa y habitualmente más sensibles con los
lazos con Rusia.
Como podéis ver, Crimea siempre ha votado
a partidos que defienden más a los rusos
étnicos. En esta zona, casi el 95% de la
población habla ruso. Y eso se nota en todas
las elecciones, tanto legislativas como presidenciales.
Todo esto explica por qué las revueltas del
Euromaidan no sentaron especialmente bien
por esta zona. Y aquí es cuando llegaron
los famosos “hombrecillos verdes”.
(Fuerzas Rusas en Crimea ¿Quienes son y de
dónde vienen? RFERL)
En 2014, Rusia envió tropas a Crimea sin
identificar. No llevaban ninguna bandera y,
por eso, se les llamó “los hombrecillos
verdes”. Es decir, que Rusia invadió militarmente
Crimea y celebró un referéndum de anexión
a Rusia. El 95% de la población votó a favor.
Y aquí podemos decir ¿De verdad fue un referéndum
democrático? ((CARCAJADA)) Evidentemente
no. Ahora bien, es muy razonable pensar que
buena parte de la población estaba a favor
de unirse a Rusia. Y, por supuesto, los que
no estaban a favor sufrieron la clásica represión
por parte de Moscú, con torturas salvajes
incluidas. Y diréis ¿Están contentos en
Crimea con ser parte de Rusia? Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(LA JOYA DEL IMPERIO DE PUTIN)
Lo primero que notaron los crimeos nada más
les invadieron los rusos fue que... la República
de Kazantip desapareció. Fin de las raves...
y caída monumental del turismo. Fueron años
difíciles para la economía local. Casi todas
las empresas ucranianas que abastecían la
península desaparecieron de un día para
otro. Y las sanciones de Occidente terminaron
por hundir el poco movimiento empresarial
que quedaba. Sin embargo... Putin tenía claro
que Crimea era su prioridad número 1.
Desde entonces, Putin ha vuelto a la clásica
estrategia de Rusificación: 140.000 tártaros
se han ido de Crimea... y, en su lugar, han
llegado más de 250.000 rusos ¡Pero no sólo
eso! Desde 2014, Moscú ha quitado recursos
de todo el país para enviarlos a Crimea.
Sí, es cierto... los habitantes de otras
zonas de Rusia no estarán muy contentos con
esta medida. Pero para Putin lo más importante
era que la economía de Crimea no terminara
de implosionar y la gente se volviera en su
contra. En total han dado más de 10.000 millones
de dólares en subsidios. Pero, por encima
de todo, han logrado sacar adelante el proyecto
más simbólico de toda la administración
de Putin: el puente de KERCH.
(Hablamos de la joya de la corona de las infraestructuras
rusas. Si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik
ya sabéis que Rusia tiene un problema serio
de infraestructuras en todo el país. Especialmente
en lo que concierne a los puentes. Pues bien,
ahora Rusia puede decir que ha construido
el puente más largo de Europa. Un puesto
que, hasta entonces, estaba reservado para
el puente Vasco de Gama, en Lisboa. El Puente
de Kerch une Rusia con Crimea a través de
19 kilómetros de carretera con 4 carriles.
Hasta 2022, lo cruzaban a diario más de 15.000
coches. Este puente es el cordón umbilical
que une Crimea con Rusia. Y ha supuesto también
un espaldarazo a su economía)
¡Pero no solo hablamos de infraestructura!
Moscú ha convertido esta península en una
auténtica fortaleza militar. Y la pregunta
ahora es ¿Puede Ucrania recuperarlo?
T4(LA GEOGRAFÍA: UN ARMA DE DOBLE FILO)
Hay más de 130 ríos y riachuelos que nacen
en las montañas de Crimea... sin embargo,
esta península sufre de escasez de agua desde
hace años. Hemos dicho que es una fortaleza
geográfica inexpugnable... pero eso también
es una debilidad: la única forma de abastecer
a Crimea por tierra es a través de las carreteras
que la conectan con Ucrania... o a través
del Puente de Kerch.
Pues bien, ambas arterias son relativamente
fáciles de atacar. De hecho, ya han sido
atacadas. Atentos.
(El Puente de Kerch que une a Rusia con Crimea
ha sido dañado tras una explosión. Al Jazeera)
¡Pero esto no es todo! ¿Recordáis que Crimea
se conecta con Ucrania por muy pocos puntos?
Uno de esos puntos es la península de Chonhar...
que está casi tocando Crimea. Aquí hay un
pequeño puente por donde pasa una autopista.
Pues... atentos.
(Rusia dice que Ucrania ha atacado el puente
de Chonhar con Crimea. CNN)
En ambos casos, hablamos de ataques muy limitados.
Los daños son relativamente fáciles de reparar.
Pero nos indican una cosa: no están 100%
seguros. Es decir, desde la posición actual,
Ucrania es capaz de atacar. Ahora imaginad
lo que podría pasar si las fuerzas ucranianas
se acercaran a esta zona aún más. Y diréis
¿Está pasando? Pues... lo cierto es que
sí. De hecho, buena parte de la contraofensiva
ucraniana se está centrando precisamente
en esta región.
Esto que veis aquí es la región de Zaporiyia,
que está muy cerca de Crimea. En el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo, las tropas
ucranianas parecen tener como objetivo avanzar
en dirección a MELITOPOL.
Si llegaran a conquistar esta zona, sería
mucho más fácil atacar todas las arterias
que conectan Crimea. Para hacer algo así,
necesitarían misiles de largo alcance. De
hecho, esta es una de las razones por las
que Washington todavía se resiste a enviar
este tipo de armamento. Pero si terminan haciéndolo,
estos misiles podrían servirles a las mil
maravillas.
Con esta estrategia, podrían secar Crimea,
tanto de agua como de otros recursos. Rusia
sólo podría abastecer su preciada península
por mar... lo cual les complicaría muchísimo
las cosas. Es casi imposible suministrar combustible
y munición en grandes cantidades a través
de aviones. En otras palabras, existe la posibilidad
de que Ucrania pueda dejar a los crimeos sin
recursos y esperar que pasen los meses.
Poco a poco, las tropas que protegen Crimea
se quedarían sin recursos para defenderse.
En ese momento, sería más fácil comenzar
un ataque por tierra. Ahora bien, seguiríamos
hablando de una operación de fuerza bruta
al mas puro estilo “desembarco de Normandía”:
Ucrania tendría que enviar ingentes cantidades
de tropas sabiendo que sacrificaría miles
de vidas.
¿Es posible que veamos este escenario? Sí.
Ahora bien... ¿Qué riesgos implicaría?
El primero es que una cosa es llegar a Crimea
y otra tomarla por completo. Recordad que
hablamos de una zona en la que siempre ha
habido un sentimiento ruso bastante fuerte.
Además, durante 8 largos años, Putin se
ha encargado de “rusificar” esta zona
a conciencia. Tanto con represión como con
ayudas económicas, y por supuesto enviando
también a decenas de miles de colonos. En
otras palabras... que Crimea no es Kharkiv,
y es muy posible que la gente no reciba a
las tropas ucranianas con los brazos abiertos.
Ahora bien... también es muy probable que
no opongan resistencia. Ya hemos visto cómo
los rusos de ROSTOV DEL DON no movieron ni
un dedo cuando pasaban los tanques de Wagner.
El segundo riesgo al que podríamos enfrentarnos
es el que decíamos al principio del vídeo:
si Putin ve que Crimea está a punto d e caer,
quien sabe, quizás podría llegar pulsar
el botón nuclear contra Ucrania. La pregunta
es ¿De verdad es capaz de hacer algo así?
Por un lado, estaríamos hablando de un auténtico
órdago, que tendría consecuencias catastróficas.
No solo por la respuesta de Occidente, sino
por sus alianzas con China y otros países.
Por otra parte, visto el poco control que
tiene Putin sobre su propia gente, no está
claro si sus generales acatarían la orden.
Visto lo visto... ni siquiera podemos asegurar
que no se vayan a sublevar antes.
Pero ahora hay otra gran pregunta ¿Puede
permitirse Ucrania olvidarse de Crimea? Pues
por poder podrían, pero sería difícil.
Mientras Crimea siga siendo parte de Rusia,
nadie podrá dormir tranquilo en Kyiv. Incluso
aunque firmaran la paz con Rusia. Moscú controlaría
el mar de Azov y podría cortarle el paso
a las exportaciones de grano desde puertos
tan importantes para Ucrania como los de Mariúpol
o Berdyansk, en caso, claro está, de que
se recuperasen.
Además, Rusia mantendría una base militar
perfecta para volver a invadir Ucrania, esta
vez desde el Sur. Y aquí llegamos al gran
dilema de Crimea: a Ucrania no le conviene
que siga siendo rusa... pero, a la vez, recuperarla
es muy caro ¿Posible solución? Un último
escenario bastante probable es que se termine
negociando un estatus especial. Es decir:
que en una hipotética negociación de paz,
Crimea termine siendo una república independiente
y desmilitarizada. Ni rusa ni ucraniana.
En cualquier caso, ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros ¿Creéis que Ucrania va a intentar
tomar Crimea militarmente? ¿O se terminara
negociando un estatus especial para esta península?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.